there's so many twists sorry I didn't
know where to go I was lost in it was so
excited to see you crystal do your thing
thing was it like for you to watch
crystal become this amazing woman shine
yet proud yeah it's like a proud father
watching her get there get her chance to
spread her wings and also have people
see her in this light because she has
done so much over the years but never
had that one big break and I'm hoping
this is the thing that opens the
floodgates so just offers for her to do
a bunch of other things how was he as a
director be honest I had about that was
long gone ever since we started doing
they haven't have knives first-day
terrified but I also knew that I could
not do my job unless I could talk to him
and ask him can I try this can I try
something from the time I asked that
question and he allowing me to do so he
has trusted me he's trusted me so much
that has caused me to trust myself oh
and that's a big gift yes that's the one
of the largest gives anybody can give an
artist I think so so to do this and do a
film with him I felt safe I trust it and
I just went on and did my best the
outcome I never expect it to be this and
it's just icing on the cake and this is
a big deal because your first original
movie for Netflix and you shot it in
your studio in Atlanta yeah it must be
emotional for you yeah it's really good
you know actually it wasn't it wasn't a
Netflix film originally I shot it
you shot I'm just gonna I've been
waiting too long to shoot it so I shot
it and that fixer like we gotta have it
and to see the audience react to it the
way that they have it's been really just
inspiring how is the Atlantis to do I
need to come down and visit I would love
to see how was it for you shooting it
there yeah it's doing really well I
think that we tried quite a bit there
they have the shot there so so it's
there's been a lot shot there feel that
it's been over three years it just
officially granted the official grand
opening was this past year but but no
it's it's wonderful that's inspirational
for so many people and that's what I
wanted it to be how do you do it you
write all your scripts you're a director
you're an actor you're fit you run the
world
like what's a typical day for you like
how's Tyler doing all this it seems like
it's a lot and it is but it seems like
it's extreme and massive but it there
but it's all moving so fast
I do building breaks for myself three
months here two months here I actually
build those breaks in all year so I can
maintain and you know do what I need to
do be a great father and figure out all
the rest of it and you wrote the script
and you write all your scripts where do
you get that inspiration I you know as a
kid I was I didn't realize this but
sometimes someone told me this there's
something called disassociative writing
I didn't know that I was even doing it
and someone said to me that it was born
out of trauma I had a lot of trauma as a
kid so my imagination is so insane I can
close my eyes and have 30 pages in 20
minutes so that's where I go to write
these stories I actually see these
things in my mind and my head and I'm
disassociated from it not really
thinking about it it's just flowing out
of me as I'm seeing it on the paper what
are you thinking right now not the
nicest boss in the world you know maybe
it's love tough love
I don't know but have you ever had a bad
experience with a boss oh please yeah
[Music]
yeah oh yeah and and I did what verses
character just did that to that boss
[Music]